فرضته فيفا على الملاعب العراقيه في نهايه
عام 2019 بسبب سوء الواقع الامني تعود
البصره لاحتضان بطوله الخليج بدورتها
الخامسه والعشرين ولم يخلو الحدث من الجدل
فدعونا نرى ما حصل
فنانون عراقيون رفضوا دعوه الاتحاد
العراقي لكره القدم ووزاره الشباب
والرياضه افتتاح حفل البطوله منهم الفنان
كاظم الساهر الذي لم يعلن عن اسباب رفضه
والفنان ماجد المهندس الذي اكد التزامه
بحفل اخر من الصعبي تاجيله الامر الذي
لاقى عتبا كبيرا من قبل جمهورهما كما سنرى
في الشعب كله الدول العربيه
بحفل افتتاح الخليج هذا انت فنان طلعت من
العراق وبديت بالعراق والعراق
[موسيقى]
على منصات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هنالك
جدلون اخر ورفض يقابله تشجيع جمهور الخليج
يجد ان العراق والبصره على وجه الخصوص لا
تزال بيئه ملغمه بالمخاطر بينما يشجع
رياضيون وشخصيات عامه خليجيه واخرى عراقيه
لاقامه الحدث وحضوره في المدينه الفيحاء
[موسيقى]
ستكون هذه المره الثانيه التي يستضيف فيها
العراق بطوله الخليج بعد ان اقيمت الاولى
في بغداد عام
1979 وتوجد فيها العراق بطلا انذاك اما
اليوم فتتعهد الجهات المنظمه والجمهور
العراقي بان تكون هذه الدوره مميزه جدا
وتبقى عالقه في ذاكرتي كل من حضرها
[موسيقى]